Hello everyone. Welcome to ACR
session on agentic AI as the cancer researcher
autonomous discovery in oncology.
AI agents are really an exciting new type and class of
artificial intelligence systems that can contribute to cancer research as
partners to human researchers. These systems can plan multi-step
analysis, potentially retrieve, organize cancer
research
and clinical data sets, use various kinds of tools and
analysis, and adapt their actions based on human
feedback and experimental results.
And so in this role, they can help researchers explore
large hypothesis spaces,
gather and connect evidence across different data sets, and support iterative
cycles of analysis and experimentation.
In this session in particular, we will examine agentic AI
systems in cancer research. We will also discuss some of
key challenges for their use in practice, including how to
apply agents to real-world data for clinical trials, what
regulatory considerations are necessary for autonomous AI
discoveries, and translational research aspects of
agentic AI with a focus on pathology and a few other data
modalities and translational aspects of agentic AI
in cancer research. The first speaker will
be Dr. Daniela Bittermann from Brigham and Women's
Hospital. Dr. Bittermann is physician scientist at the
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute in Boston and Brigham and Women's
Hospital, with unique expertise in AI and natural language processing.
Her research is dedicated to incorporating technological advances in AI
into intelligent electronic health record systems to improve
data-driven cancer care. And in her talk, Dr.
Bittermann will focus on late-stage discovery, touching on
agents applied to real-world data and clinical trials, and she will also discuss
some of regulatory considerations for autonomous AI discoveries as
part of her topic. So I'll now welcome Dr.
Bittermann to present on agentic AI for clinical development in
oncology. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. zitnick, and thank you everyone for
being here and the opportunity to present.
Here are my disclosures.
So as likely most people in the audience know,
there have been persistent bottlenecks to oncology clinical
development. There is a massive amount of
investment upfront by biopharmaceutical
companies in research and development.
But as you go from initial investment to the pre-clinical
phase, early phase one, phase two, phase three, you
ultimately get to a point where only about 10% of compounds that
enter a clinical trial advance to FDA approval.
And each time a drug fails to make it successfully
from phase two to phase three, we lose an opportunity to
improve care for patients. The patients who've enrolled on those trials
would not have had the opportunity to be a part of a potentially
more successful trial, and all of the investment that
went into that one drug ends up being
lost because it was diverted away from other potentially promising compounds.
And so if we could advance this whole process, improve the efficiency, improve the
likelihood that we can either
rapidly identify that a drug is unlikely to
demonstrate benefit in a phase three trial or
improve the efficiency with which we're able to conduct a phase three trial, we'll
really accelerate the
pace of
improving management in cancer care.
And so there are multiple bottlenecks that contribute to this process.
Here I'm highlighting just a few key points.
One is patient selection.
We tend to take a fairly blunt approach to
identifying cohorts for clinical trials.
This is due to limitations in our ability to risk
stratify patients based on
pre-clinical data and real-world evidence.
This leads to diluted signal and limited information to drive
go/no-go decisions. If we're able to more precisely select
patients, we can potentially run a clinical trial
with fewer patients due to improved signal-to-noise ratio.
Another challenge is access. Many clinical trials are run at large
academic medical centers that don't necessarily
reach all of the patients that are treated every day in cancer
in the community. If we're able to unlock all of the community sites where the
full diversity of cancer patients receive care, we'll
have a much broader base to recruit from.
Execution is a challenge.
It takes multiple weeks to start up a
study at a clinical site.
Activation and staffing all delay studies and require a lot of resources,
which is challenging in an increasingly resource-limited setting.
And finally, there's bottlenecks in our ability to rapidly
access clinical data, both for real-world evidence generation to
guide development decision-making, as
well as to proactively and rapidly identify signal
for our clinical trials. This is because clinical data are highly fragmented in
silos.
Patients are treated at many different sites, and it's very
difficult to integrate technologies to extract information from
EHR warehouses, and get that
information that's documented on patients
to the clinical
monitorsSo
there's a lot of potential of AI in general to improve clinical development
processes and in particular agentic AI.
So I'm just going to take a quick step back and define what I'm talking about when
I say agentic AI, because there are multiple different
definitions of it.
And I'd like to
highlight a really wonderful paper by Dr.
Truin that goes through the differences
between single
LLM, single AI, all the way to autonomous agentic workflows.
So we're all likely familiar with the standard large language
model approach, where
a human puts in a query into a large language model.
This could be a question, what is a
high value drug to
proceed to clinical trial? Or it can be, can you tell me what this note says about
a patient? And there's a single output.
You can use this to answer questions, summarize text, or draft new
text.
Sometimes you can extend this a little bit further where you have a large language
model iteratively interact with a human in a conversational setting, and
that human might be able to access tools or instruct the language model to
use
tools. This can allow a system
to perform
more complex tasks, but still requires quite a lot of human input and
is not fully automated, still presenting
challenges with efficiencies.
An autonomous LLM agent is where a
large language model, or it can be other machine learning models,
plans multi-step tasks, execute tasks, iterates, refines,
and determines whether or not a tool is needed to be called so that it can
explore an environment with agency to answer an
input query. This allows these models to solve much more
complex tasks,
with a lot more clinical nuance, because you can more rapidly embed clinical
information into these environments that these agents
interact within. So really a high potential for
general
clinical oncology automation and in particular clinical development.
So why is agentic AI particularly exciting for the clinical development workflow?
And I think this is because a lot of our challenges is not just challenges with our
ability to access data or collect data, but really there are
multi-step workflow challenges that require really deep coordination and
iteration across many different fragmented systems that hold
different data types. As I previously mentioned, clinical data are
fragmented, non-standardized, and require a high level of clinical
reasoning to reason over effectively.
Decisions regarding clinical development must keep pace with a really rapidly
evolving biomedical literature base, and relying only
on human review makes it challenging to ensure that you're, for
example,
selecting the most appropriate comparator for your experiments.
Clinical development workflows are multi-step inherently and require a lot of
coordination, so are a natural fit for agentic AI.
And insights to clinical development are not a one-stop kind of,
we found this finding, and this is the answer, but it actually triggers timely
action. So, for example, you have an insight where you have a patient that's
developing early signal of an adverse event.
You don't just stop saying this patient's having early signal of adverse event.
Ideally, you have an action where
the clinical trialist then acts on that
adverse event per protocol.
Agentic AI can play a lot of roles throughout the clinical development continuum.
Here I'm highlighting just a few examples.
Agentic AI is really critical
to use currently human expertise to define
the goals to go after when
triggering an agentic investigation into a
challenge.
Agentic AI can be used to help develop the evidence
base to guide clinical development decisions.
You can use AI to rapidly assess prior
literature of the
standard of care and predictors. You can use it to generate real-world
evidence, and you can use it to
develop biomarkers for better patient selection.
That can then go to inform clinical development strategy ranging from what is
the optimal trial design, what patient stratification options can
be used, what endpoints should be selected, and what's the appropriate regulatory
pathway for your clinical trial.
Then moving to execution, agents can then take the evidence and
strategy and automatically draft a protocol or
regulatory submission
pre-drafts.
Agentic AI in the future with high integration with
clinical sites can be used to automate site activation, for example,
to automatically help set up EDCs for a given
trial.
Patient matching has received a lot of attention with agentic AI,
and agentic AI can be used to automatically monitor patients for outcomes that need
action. All of this can go to inform decision-making about the dosing
schedule, eligibility criteria, safety adverse events, and
go/no-go decisions to accelerate clinical development.
And ideally, all of this works in a
cycle where agentic insights then
go into inform what is the next evidence that we need
to further refine our trial design or
further refine our next drug
decisions.
Now I'm going to quickly go into an example of how my lab has been using agentic
AI for one part of this workflow, which is
monitoring of adverse events in real time from electronic health
records.So a current
bottleneck for real-world data abstraction as well as for clinical
trial
curation is that we currently rely largely on manual abstraction
for a lot of the information that's documented in the EHR.
This is because all data in the EHR tend to be highly
non-standardized, and a lot of it's entered in the clinical notes, which
require manual review historically.
And it requires providers to pore through
large
amounts of clinical records to determine what happened to a patient at a given
point in time.
This is time-intensive, expertise-intensive, costly,
and has a high degree of
inter-annotator agreement, where two
expert oncologists might disagree on whether the same event occurred on a given
patient.
To address this challenge, we developed an agentic AI system
that takes in clinical notes and
extracts adverse events, specifically immunotherapy-related adverse
events, from those notes. It first determines whether
an event is present in a clinical note,
grades the severity of the notes according to
CTCAE definitions, determines whether that adverse
event is attributed to the immunotherapy, and
determines the certainty with which that adverse event is
attributed to the immunotherapy.
This leads to a pipeline that goes from a fully unstructured clinical
note that historically would have required human review to structured
output in a JSON file
that clearly delineates whether an IRE is present, the grade attribution,
and the underlying clinical evidence for the attribution.
Our system achieved a macro F1 of 0.93.
It takes a human 10 minutes to do the careful curation for all
adverse events present in a clinical document, and it takes
our LLM system two cents to review a note for all
this evidence.
Because our agentic system is able to extract the underlying text
that provides evidence for the adverse event, as well as provide a reasoning
summary for why the determination was made, we're able to develop
an interactive system that our research staff
can use to oversee the system and make edits if needed.
Our research staff found that highlighting this text was particularly helpful in
guiding their review and saving
time in the process.
We conducted a randomized user effect study where we randomized clinical
research staff to using our agentic system versus manual curation
and found that using our system reduced the time needed to curate adverse
events by 40%.
It led to similar
accuracy in adverse event determination compared to an expert
oncologist,
and I think really importantly, significantly improved the
inter-annotator agreement or consistency with which two research
staff will agree on the adverse event.
So we are making this process more
efficient. We're not leading to decrements
in accuracy or data quality, and actually we're improving the consistency,
so reducing noise in adverse event determinations.
So we found this to be really promising, and just as kind of
a step back, where could we go from here in terms of using an
agentic system, focus on adverse event detection to really
better understand the role of adverse event and predict adverse
events to guide clinical development.
So
drawing back from our adverse event extraction system, you can imagine
a much broader system that, for example, uses real-world data
and
AI-assisted literature review to allow us to better anticipate
adverse event rates and determine imaging or
biomarker-based
predictors of adverse event risk to better guide patient selection.
This could then inform a strategy into risk-adapted cohorts to improve the
signal-to-noise ratio and allowing for a more
precise determination of who is most likely to benefit with the fewest
risks
for a given treatment strategy.
Moving on to execution, I think
using our system just to extract those
adverse events more reliably and faster would really make it easier for clinical
sites to run these clinical trials.
An agentic workflow could also pre-position adverse event management
in the SOPs and allow for continuous
monitoring for early intervention of an adverse event to reduce the
risk that an early adverse event progresses to a grade three or four or five
event.
Finally, this could improve decision-making about clinical development.
By improving detection of an emerging adverse event signal, you could
facilitate grade triggered holds and more precise causality assessment,
which is a really persistent challenge in
determining the risks and benefits of a new management strategy,
especially as patients are treated with many modalities over long
periods of time as patients are living longer
and longer after their initial cancer diagnosis.
Now, there's one really persistent challenge with using large language models
in general and agentic systems in particular
in any high-risk critical setting and any
highly regulated site setting, such as clinical development, of course.
Our current standard approaches for evaluating the performance of
these large language models largely relies on types of
multi-choice question answer exams that
can be automatically assessed. You ask a
question of
an agentic system and give it multiple options to select from,
and it can choose the right answer, and then you can calculate the
accuracy.The challenge is this does not
necessarily reflect the type of real-world applications that we would
really want to use these agentic AI systems in.
And we don't know if performance in these
multi-choice question answer settings really translates
to similar performance in real-world applications.
Real-world applications, like this example showing here, are often
have generative output and rely on
faithful reasoning steps across agentic systems and reliable
extraction from the correct evidence base.
All of that requires a much higher level of coordination of
monitoring and benchmarking strategies themselves.
Sound scientific judgment and multi-step reasoning abilities are
currently not covered by our evaluation strategy, which I think is a really high
priority for future research in order to ensure
that agentic insights that inform clinical trial design and
determinations are fully auditable and reportable
when presenting ultimately to regulatory bodies.
Now, a lot of focus with large language models and agentic
AI systems currently is on retrospective
performance
on prior data sets. We have models that really do
perform impressively well. Like the agentic system I previously showed, it got an
F1 of 0.93 that's
very, very high sensitivity and positive predictive value
for determining and fully phenotyping adverse events documented in
EHRs. But that doesn't necessarily mean that these systems are
ready to just turn on and use to extract information or
provide high-value insights for clinical development.
That's because currently the challenge with agentic systems is not the
performance of the models, in my opinion.
It's all the other work that has to go into making agentic systems a
reality. Data integration with agentic systems is super
important. You can think of agentic systems like
workers
using tools on a conveyor belt. The workers need to be able to anticipate
what type of data that they are pulling from in order to
do their job. If you don't have high-quality data integration, standardization,
harmonization, that conveyor belt approach is going to fall apart really
rapidly. You need to ensure value to
demonstrate the need
and
return on investment of
building the
agentic workflows and its surrounding governance approach.
Monitoring model drift and data drift, as I previously mentioned, is
really important for any highly regulated setting, in particular this, and
governance bodies need to be set up to ensure that
the ethical approach and
safety are
being governed in a responsible way.
All of this requires a lot, currently the lion's
share of effort for implementing agentic AI in clinical systems.
And finally,
patients are really the core of what we do and need to be
deeply engaged in any conversation about clinical research and
clinical trials,
including the use of AI in clinical trials and clinical development.
This is a survey that was run by Cancer Nation of cancer survivors
assessing their comfort and trust in AI as part of their
cancer care. Here, they bucketed
responses by age group.
Overall, a minority of patients for any use case were very
comfortable with AI being used in their care
and were predominantly comfortable with the use of AI for administrative
tasks, much less comfortable with the use of AI
for clinical tasks.
Clinical trials must
engage
our patients in the conversation of using AI to
ensure
conduct and trust and ongoing patient participation and engagement in trials.
There are risks of both hype and underestimating
any technology, and there's a lot of hype about agentic AI right
now. There are risks of moving too fast.
You can't move fast and break things in healthcare.
That's a cliché. But there are also risks of not moving fast enough.
Premature adoption and overpromising will cause backlash when performance falls
short, and therefore unrealized benefits due to
backlash and slower long-term uptake and inadequate
implementation.
On the flip side, dismissing innovation and having unrealistic performance
requirements slows progress and can potentially push people
to using AI inappropriately and in non-regulated settings.
So to summarize, agentic AI has potential to accelerate and augment evidence
generation, strategy, operational execution, and decision-making in clinical
development. Near-term use cases include biomarker development, patient
stratification, patient matching, automated outcome monitoring, and document
preparation.
Data integration, infrastructure monitoring, and governance require upfront
effort but will compound value as models continue to advance.
And rigorous evaluation, benchmarking, and scalable oversight strategies
are top priorities for responsible, safe, and regulatory-grade deployment of
these systems in clinical development.
So I'd like to thank my collaborators and my funders,
and thank you for the opportunity to present here today.
Thank you, Dr. Peterman. We have time for one question.
Does it work? Yep.
Go ahead.
Hi. Very nice talk. I was wondering,
clinical trials are really multifactorial.
You have many things you have to do to make them happen.
I was wondering, you mentioned in one of your slides that you were working on
matching patients to trials, so kind of probably use agentic AI to
improve accrual. I was wondering if you could comment on your
progress on that side.
So, my group is not working on agentic AI for trial
matching. There is a lot of ongoing effort in this space on trial
matching. I will say our immune-related adverse event project, which is focused
really on
more accurately collecting adverse events, is
currently being prospectively tested by evaluating whether it improves
accrual to an immune-related adverse event biobank, in which, in that case,
that special case, the immune-related adverse event is an
eligibility criteria. But that's a fairly simple protocol with
only a few
eligibility criteria. It's performing really
well.
But there's many other groups that are tackling this challenge of
patient matching. It's really hard in oncology because we have these really
lengthy, complex eligibility criteria that are written in
a non-standardized way. I think to really accelerate this,
kind of upfront standardizing eligibility criteria will really make it
much easier to implement. And there's a lot of great work, I see my colleagues out
here, coming out of the NCI and CBIT in standardizing eligibility
criteria to make that a more realistic reality.
Thank you.
Thank you. We'll have a bit more time for the general discussion at the
end of this session, but for now, we need to proceed with the next speaker,
and this will be Dr. Sebastian Firsch from University Medical
Center
Mainz in Germany. Dr. Firsch is physician, scientist, and pathologist
at the Institute of Pathology at University Medical Center Mainz.
His research focuses on applying AI to digital pathology,
particularly for cancer diagnosis, prognosis, and clinical decision
support. And in his talk, he will present on translational clinical
research aspects of agentic AI with a particular
focus on pathology.
Okay, I look forward to this presentation.
Yeah. Thank you so much for the kind introduction and also